i mean salmon just have like mayonnaise
and like ketchup and all that [ __ ] in it
i don't need that [ __ ] okay you're out
of the question
where where does all the crusts go in
japan where is it where's all the crusts
gone
i don't know probably for some reason
all the sandwiches don't have crusts on
them where is it give me my [ __ ]
crust i love the crust
i think though sometimes i actually
that's the reason i like japanese
sandwiches and some okay in some cases
like you can't have mayo you can't eat
the [ __ ] crust on your this man
doesn't like
it's still bread yeah man what's what's
the problem it tastes good yeah
i just i just it's just it's just wasted
wasted bread that's like tasteless
bread it's like it's the it tastes like
bread no it's the flavor dude it's the
best part
that's so good it tastes like cardboard
no it doesn't no it's what yeah it
tastes exactly like the bread that it's
like
it's like the crust on pizza okay yeah
why why does crust on pizza exist and
why does everyone pretend
it's good it tastes good no it doesn't
you eat the pizza
for the [ __ ] bread cheese tomato
sauce why would why would i want to eat
pizza
that is why would i just want to eat the
bread part of the pizza where when i
have pizza
i want the pizza part of the pizza okay
that's because you're eating it wrong
right you're going right up to the crust
yeah you've got to save a little bit of
the sauces
people think of a [ __ ] psychopath
when i eat pizza the way i actually eat
pizza at home
which is crust first i eat the crust
first because
i get i get the taste of [ __ ] out of the
way so more i'm waiting
then how do you hold the pizza i just
hold it like like what the [ __ ] are you
doing bro
you're holding you're holding it like el
dude like look look look i i just saved
the best part to last why would i save
the tasteless part till last
i don't enjoy it but you're making
you're making it tasteless by only
eating the crust
if if you save a little bit of the sauce
that sauce could be with the actual
pizza
you know what i mean but but the pizza
has plenty of sauce look it's like it's
like eating the [ __ ]
it's like when you're having a nice
[ __ ] meal and you eat your broccoli
and vegetables first and you
and you have like your chicken and your
steak afterwards you save the best part
of your life
you always eat everything separate not
always if
it like synergizes perfectly if it like
you would know i thought you would
[ __ ]
cross the house with the pizza no it
doesn't
the crust just takes the pizza tastes
like an italian handle this piece like
it synergizes because when you get those
shitty frozen pizzas right that are like
one dollar yeah right they're the ones
with no crust
you know those [ __ ] fake deep dish
pizzas that are just all bread yeah like
the thinnest
[ __ ] horrible that's like his [ __ ]
dream no my my my [ __ ] dream
is like proper thin crust
italian pizzas where like the the the
pizza goes
right up to the crust and it's because
it's so thin it doesn't take it doesn't
get in the way
it doesn't get in the way sorry you got
a grip on something
i don't give a [ __ ] about greasy [ __ ]
hands if the pizza tastes better
that's just optimizing the pizza there
is so much wasted space on pizza
that's it's it's like the crust gets in
the way of the pizza taste well then
okay why don't you do this then when you
get the pizza next time right and
there's a thick crust just fold that
[ __ ] in half
oh yeah no because that's like that's
like that means i feel like you're
making a problem out of this
no no no no no no no just roll up the
pizza so that it's all in one thing and
then
i just assume right whenever i see
anyone who you know leaves their crusts
on a sandwich
or you know leaves the crusts on a pizza
i'm like your parents clearly didn't
like
beat it into you yeah [ __ ] dude dude if
i if i left crosstalk
my mom would beat myself she would
murder me she'd be like why are you
wasting food
i'll be like i got away with a lot of
[ __ ] but leaving food was not one of
them yeah no that's why that's why if i
have to eat pizza i eat it crust first
um like it's just
you make it sound like a [ __ ] torture
man it is torture for me because you're
ruining
you're ruining this good [ __ ] food
with just tasteless bread there's only
one time where it's acceptable to leave
the crusts on a pizza and that is a
buffet
of pizza where it's like i gotta
optimize this yeah
and also and also in like crush just
takes extra room
it's just extra room in your stomach
that can be filled with nice tasty pizza
i don't want to get filled up with like
tasteless crust
i don't want that [ __ ] pizza okay who
is your stomach
oh yes this tiny bit of crust here as
well i know i'm right
i am not the crazy one here how do i
i have been quiet about this for too
long
crossless gang where you at where are
you at cross the sky crossland
10 year olds raised there
[Applause]
point is where is the crush japan give
me i don't i don't like it they take it
for me because
sometimes i think the best part of the
sandwich is like the the give that the
cream
adds to it right you gotta bite it yeah
yeah yeah tug it a little bit yeah
sometimes it just crumbles apart without
the crust it's like the integrity of
this
sandwich has been ruined it's it's been
optimized
you cut off all the useless pieces
although i will say sometimes
7-eleven is the by far the guiltiest of
this you'll get a sandwich from 7-eleven
right and they'll show you the sandwich
it looks like [ __ ] packed in the
front
yeah yeah yeah this thing is like
quadruple ham slices right you
you open up this sandwich thing you you
get it out you're like oh my god it's
thick and then as you realize you grab
it in your hand you're like huh
it's really really thin pretty thin at
the end you peel it up and there's no
ham
yeah yeah yeah the other half of the
sandwich and you're like i've been
[ __ ] playing you got [ __ ] click
baited by seriously yeah yeah
i think you have to like weirdly like
curl the bread up so you can get like an
even bite of bread it's [ __ ] 7-eleven
can you [ __ ] sort that [ __ ] out
everyone says their food is the best but
it's honestly the worst one out of the
family mode it's okay family must the
worst no i i i have to stand with family
mart
oh my god no i'm i'm a i'm a 7-eleven
simp man
i i'm you're an awesome
we're going to leave this for the
conbini tournament arc okay we'll do it
we need to
ask there are three genders